it was either you or grandma and grandpa
and he looks right at me and he goes
well they do like each other a lot
i said you say my mom watches porn he
goes no i didn't say that you said that
i think it's clear that i didn't jacob
did it and didn't jacob didn't did it i
didn't then it wasn't my mom it was and
it was jake it wasn't my wife and i we
went to hawaii for vacation my parents
came to stay with them we got a direct
tv bill a month later and there's 200
worth of porn charges
we're looking at the bill you know it's
such an old person thing to order porn
off a tv right why would i be doing that
you're getting a little too defensive up
front that's how i know you're guilty
i'm mad i'm mad mad right the dude needs
to be taught a lesson because porn is
free like how dumb do you have to be
i got pouring in my pocket 24 hours a
day
i'm worried about him as a human being
if he's still paying for porn that is
the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever
heard of
i'm worried about him walking around in
this world if he's still paying for porn
like how is he gonna do that
i tell my wife i'm like i gotta go down
and talk to him this is so dumb this is
gonna be a quick conversation because
his mo when he lies is he'll lie and
then if you just show him facts
he's like yo that was me and that's it
i'm playing the innocence until you
prove that i'm guilty i'm like all right
but i can't argue that anymore i knew if
i landed on the right thing you'd just
be like yep cool
so i have the facts in my hand i have
the bill in my hand so i figure it's
gonna be quick conversation so i go down
into his room and i'm like hey man you
know anything about this
and here's how i could tell he was gonna
lie to me
because as soon as i held up the bill
he bent over and he squinted like he
couldn't read all of a sudden he was
like if you posted a picture of that
yeah you might get canceled oh yeah
you're right even when there was nothing
to read if you were caught in a lie
you were
i'm not sure what that list of stuff is
how much it's porn he goes oh
i go you don't know anything about that
porn he goes no i know cause i'm looking
at the dates it's when your mom and i
were out of town
and the only people at the house were
you
and grandma and grandpa
it's my mom and it's you
and i would assume that you are watching
porn before my mom she might be
fascinated with technology nowadays she
didn't have it when she was my age are
you saying
my mom is watching porn now because it's
just more available than it used to be
well you said it i just like made a
statement about it that means you said
it so it was either you or
grandma and grandpa and he looks right
at me and he goes
well they do like each other a lot
i said you say my mom watches porn he
goes no i didn't say that you said that
is it crazy that we just did that i
remember you turning that around on me
i'm like no i didn't say it you said it
you're like no i didn't say it you said
it i'm just agreeing with you
technically i didn't say it you implied
it right but the words never came out of
my mouth the words came out of your
mouth why is he so confident i have the
bill i have it right here i'm gonna make
him so uncomfortable that he'll admit it
so i guess i'll just start reading off
the titles of the movies
are you telling me
that grandma and grandpa
were in my room
watching
anal party 3.
and this is the quote out of his mouth
well the door was shut all weekend
you would think you would at least throw
me a bone and be like yeah it was me
because then i wouldn't have to think
that my mom was watching anal party 3.
say
roles are reversed me and your mom are
staying with your kid i'm asking you
first because based off of this if it
happens in the future you're going to
try and pull some [ __ ] on me to reverse
the joke that's why i would obviously
ask you first because i know your ass
would plan 25 years in the [ __ ]
future you're right get me back on a
joke i'm playing the [ __ ] long game
i've known that 100 crazy i've already
told your mom hey when jacob has kids
however we do it i'm ordering porn and
i'm charging it to him and i'm blaming
it on his kid
i said are you saying my mom watches
anal he goes no you said that i never
said that
you kept throwing back that back at me
because you kept screaming it at me i
don't know what you wanted to say the
reason he was so confident was the only
way i can truly prove that it was him
is if i call my parents
and i say
did you watch anal party 3
in my room
and on the off chance they say yes i got
to burn the [ __ ] house down like i
can't live there as an adult male if my
parents are watching anal on your bed
you're going to burn that [ __ ] down
that's another thing just peace of mind
i can't think about that i slept on a
bed that my mom and dad were watching
anal party three on you say you're doing
it for peace of mind but based on this
you don't have any pieces i have zero
pieces yeah that's the best part yeah
when you first saw the joke what were
you thinking i definitely didn't do it
he could tell the joke all he wants but
it's not me so i decided he's gone all
in he knows i don't want to call my
parents the only way i can bust him is
if i go all in too and i say to him i go
you didn't order porn and then he did
say what every teenager says at least
once i wish you'd just believe me oh
that was my favorite
i haven't heard you do it a long time
just do it once from it oh yeah
every kid did that because everybody got
caught in the wild once
you never believe me oh
i don't know man
i believe you and he goes whoa
because i figured i'm pushing all my
chips in too the only way to get him is
to admit it is to get him into a
situation that he doesn't want to be in
so i said yeah man
i believe you and i think it's terrible
that grandma and grandpa are making you
pay for their porn he was like yeah i
think that's terrible too because you
were so adamant about me ordering the
porn and that your mom didn't i'm not
gonna say your parents anymore i'm just
gonna say your mom that's gonna bother
you
we gotta call him out he was like i
agree with you let's just get him on the
phone
and he looks me dead in the eye and he
goes call him
when you said call him what was the
thought process no matter what hillary
went down whether grandpa decided to
blame me or they came out and said the
truth
i was ready for the ride i was ready for
the roller coaster because i just wanted
to hear you ask let's say you're telling
the truth which i am not
which
which
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
were you expecting them to admit it
no
only the two of you know so it's funny
because i've never talked about this
right i did ask my dad i go hey did you
order the porn and he goes jacob hasn't
said anything and i was like nah and
he's like
well then i'm not gonna mommy but he
knows the answer you both know the
answer and he's running it with me now
so i start to dial one number
dial another number and he goes
you don't have your parents on speed
dial when you said that i was like
it was so cocky i liked it so much you
were ready you're like let's get this
phone call happening yeah man because i
think you knew i was never gonna call i
knew you were bluffing yeah there was no
way what if my mom answered exactly i'm
going slow i'm giving you a chance to
come clean he goes i wouldn't say come
clean when you talk to them and i was
like
listen guys if this is a fight he's
landed every [ __ ] punch so far i'm
pressing another button
press another button guys i'm at like
the eighth button i'm like i'm about to
ask my parents if they watched anal
party three i was so nervous i think i
saw you sweating you don't give up on
bits you go all in nobody else is
hanging out of the bow you're still in
the titanic like we still got a chance
yeah
everybody's already given up and on a
lifeboat and i'm sitting there the
captain's like we got that about to
press that ninth button and he goes whoa
i'll pay for it
and i said you ordered the porn he goes
no that was grandma and grandpa i just
don't want you to embarrass them i think
it's nice how much they like each other
this was a gangster move on so many
levels what you did is you made sure
that i never knew the answer you never
got a definitive yes or no
and
you also knew that i was gonna end up
paying for the bill and probably never
ask you for the money even at that age
you knew you were like wait wait wait
wait
not knowing is going to be way worse
than knowing right 100 it's a great joke
because it's never ending isn't as long
as you and grandpa
never say anything and neither one of
you says yeah
it hangs over my head like a
[ __ ] anvil he looks me dead in the
eye and he goes
we done here and i was like
yeah i guess so uh
but that wasn't satisfactory to me guys
i needed to hear him say he ordered the
porn right so we get to the outside of
his door and i'm on the outside of it
and i go hey man before you before
before i leave i'm going to give you one
last offer i
will pay the bill and give you 200
all you gotta do is say you ordered the
point
and he looks right at me and he goes
nope
grandma grandpa
and now every time he walks by my room
and the door is open he looks in and he
goes i wouldn't sleep on that bed best
line ever offering a 16 year old would
be 400 bucks but to me it's just 200
that's when it clicked in my head that's
when i was playing the game at that
point you were like i don't even care if
you did it or didn't i just need to hear
the words yes i ordered the porn come
out of my mouth so that you could take
the thought of your parents or your
mother out of your head you giving me
the peace of mind that i wanted wasn't
worth only two hundred dollars oh [ __ ]
the joke is too good knowing now i would
have been like here's a thousand dollars
just say you ordered the porn so you had
that look on your face like
is two hundred dollars worth
letting him off the hook 100 with my
head because you're like that's 400
bucks i'm like no because it's 200
because i'm only getting 200 of it that
was the thing for me i was like you
actually giving me 400 maybe cash cash
in hand by the way and it would be over
by now and i may not have ever released
that i may not have ever even done a
joke no because there was a satisfactory
entering form might have just been a fun
story that we told i like gatherings or
whatnot now it's a story we tell the
gatherings that's not so fun for you
right i think it's clear that i didn't
jacob did it
and didn't jacob did
it was and it was jacob it wasn't yeah
nope
if you guys like the content and and
like everything here and want to see
more hit that like button subscribe and
hit that notification button and leave a
comment too who knows one of us might
comment back absolutely as usual thank
you guys so much for watching and uh we
have a podcast coming out soon called
hey man hey man um hey man it should be
a whole lot of fun it is a whole lot of
fun uh make sure you guys tune into that
and we'll see you guys soon on the next
one later